[Music]
let's take you live to kabul now where
taliban's spokesman is
holding a news conference let's listen
to what he has to say
people
that debate
this situation
and they didn't
i thank them for their patience
[Music]
which was the nest for the final list
for the enemy of afghanistan
which has been cleared today
completely
and all afghan forces have
presence there
more fightings in the country but
unfortunately
a number of people that they fled
with a number of people's property and
ammunitions
and security of the people of
afghanistan from there
they should have talked about the
reconstruction of their own country
rather than
putting us into
challenges
the
islamic american afghanistan wants to
negotiate this matter and resolve this
the
negotiations
commanders in parwan and panchay and all
those who were involved this war they
were used
in this
to to resolve this matter through
negotiations and dialogue
they were still thinking
they received negative answers and they
couldn't resolve the matter to
negotiations on dialogue
so the islamic immigrants
decided to send their
military forces to get rid of this the
final nest of the terrorism
we want different peace to our country
and if anyone if anyone
caused problem or cause insecurity and
safety in any point of afghanistan the
islamic america afghanistan will take
categoric decision and will not allow
anyone
[Music]
foreign
should be a place of reconstruction
and rebuilding
i hope the nation help us in this
process
and hope god will help us as well
pick up arms and
start resistance
okay if you're just joining us it seems
we've lost translation but we're just
hearing a press conference from the
taliban spokesman zahid mujahid i
believe we have translation let's
continue to listen in therefore we hope
the nation is with us and we help the
nation to help us and we still require
the
cooperation and assistance over
the second point is that i would like to
thank our mujahide nation who was part
of our body and our soul
and also
we can't even imagine
that ordinary members of the pactual
mujahideen of pancho
and those people who were using the name
of that valley
and the name of the
people
in
with evil intentions
we want to
repeat that the people of pancho exactly
the same like people of herod and
kandahar and kabul and mother sharif
are respectable for us
and we will not
treat people differently
our pantry brother brothers
have
the same respect
as exactly the same like other people in
the country
the
[Music]
um
for safety and security and peace
and or have been selected from those
groups that they are acceptable for by
all
we didn't have any civilian casualties
during the
taking over
fight shared by military forces
as a result of the fightings there was a
shortage of food or medication
in panchayat and from now on
[Music]
and also the telephone communications
will be reconnected to the province
have left the country
and only to save themselves save their
lives
we want to assure all the
security forces in the country that the
islamic
republic afghanistan
that our forces are in every part of the
city and country
and they have total control
over the whole country
they want to stop
those people who do not have uniforms
they are not allowed in the city or they
will be removed from the
city they cannot interfere with
government affairs
in the past few hours
about 340 thieves and
burglars have been
captured in the couple's city
those people who stop people's cars got
into people's houses and dropped people
they have all been captured in the
kabul
two or three days ago we came across
with an incident that people were shot
issue firing shots in the air and as a
result many people were
killed and got injured
and people's
comfort and safety was disturbed
in this regard also about 80 percent of
people who
[Music]
shot in the air who have been arrested
and
because they
misused the property of the people and
the government by
firing shots in the air
and have taken full control over the
situation and we have announced that
nobody can fire shots in the air anymore
because people cannot hear
one more shot
the sound one more shot in the air is
too much for the people to hear
the kabul airport is one of the most
important airports in the country
serious steps has been taken in order
the qatar country and
turkish government are very busy there
to
make the kabul airport operational
domestic flights has already started and
we are just waiting to
hear when can we start
overseas flights
[Music]
technical side and
putting the
radar system back in place
and we want people to be a little bit
patient with us
start overseas
very soon
for commercial and military purposes
and when americans left they badly
damaged the airport
airplanes and also even the radar system
was dismantled and damaged badly
this was the
animosity towards our country and
people our people should remember
and also the media should remember
the occupation the occupiers never build
our country they can never build our
country we will think that the occupiers
can build our country that's a
wrong
interpretation
the invaders are here to destroy our
country
but we
in fact we should
take the responsibility of uh
reconstruction and building ourselves
in the meanwhile the reconstruction
rebuilding and repair of the kabul
airport is ongoing
also we have been receiving um
humanitarian aids from the uh foreign
like food and medication
many countries have
made i mean and assistance
to our country
and they are doing their best to
help us
their
food medication and other stuff that
they have helped to our country
so it will be and it will be distributed
and i would like to
thank our neighboring countries and also
ask our neighboring countries and
international community to not stop
their humanitarian assets
to afghanistan
i would like to assure the international
community
[Music]
and i would like to ask them to help us
it will take time to receive their
humanitarian
assistance
will be received in afghanistan
slowly
[Music]
the currency rate and regardless of the
currency rate the rate of the afghani is
stable and
we start to
operate that channel as well so people
will transfer money and receive money
from overseas
uh we know that
there's another situation that
there's another problem that the
the poverty and the
economical
situation of the people
hopefully we have this opportunity to
that we have peace in the country
hopefully the situation will get better
and the economy will improve
and people will be out of the poverty
it seems we've lost that translation if
you are just joining us we're just
watching a press conference uh
being held by the taliban spokesman
zabihullah mujahid in kabul
we can go back to the translation let's
listen in
the economy of the
you shouldn't country any concerns and
worries and we will have
relationships with the
international community
in this regard
and you can ask your questions please
where are those
and religious clerics
and elders are in contact with panchi
and those people who were in control of
panchayat they are missing at the moment
i can still tell them that afghanistan
is their home they can come back to
afghanistan anytime they want
and this is their country
if they have left the country they can
come back to afghanistan
and also in relation to the airport
kabul airport
the damage to the kabul airport is
huge
as i mentioned that the
technical side of it the radar has also
has been damaged and it needs time to be
repaired
islamic immigrant
[Music]
we have we received videos and footages
that they were defeated uh during this
war and will will this be an
all-inclusive government
the
decision has been taken and has been
finalized
to announce the government
we want to do a proper job
when we announce the government
and i don't know the details of it yet
they were old weapons and new weapons
and also taken from kabul to panchayat
all those weapons will be returned to
the um
weapons cash in afghanistan to belong to
the government of afghanistan
[Music]
um
if you could give us some information
about that
first of all i want to give you some
information about the once we announce
the government and then we'll give you
detailed information about
the structure of the government
it will be an all-inclusive government
because
the changes
needs to be made
hopefully i will be able to answer this
question after i announce the government
what was the next question
we don't have any reports that somebody
have been arrested
we
in regards to control the situation um
in in kabul we have uniformed personnel
in kabul to ensure the safety and
security uh in
kabul
and stop an arrest
investigate matters which
causes disturbance to the people
and
once the government is announced and
then then the government will decide
what
we will do with those
burglars or thieves or
criminals
[Music]
the new government was due to be
announced on friday
what will be the new system of the
government like
those people those organizations or
those parties that you fought against
for the past 20 years will they have a
part in the taliban's government
[Music]
in the past
hopefully our government
will cover them
under
the same umbrella
of armed forces and they can return to
the armed forces to their units
i would like to say that our country
needs a very strong military
and
that our afghans have that have received
trainings
they will be part of our
military force
including our own
forces
that they fought with us in the past 20
years also
we will select them based on their
criteria and
competence
well once we should allow the government
to start its work
and then we will look at the
constitution and other areas of the
government
and
whether to
bring changes or reform it or not
the government will start whether there
will be any reforms in the
constitution's constitution or not
it should be an islamic
a strong
and all-inclusive constitution
this will be done in future
there's so many people
there in this pinball deck and
they haven't been able to work or live
and they can't cross the border have you
spoken with the government of pakistan
in relation to these people that they
cannot move
i should say that
our afghans have had problems
on the crossing points at the borders
recently
especially in particularly in chairman
and torham
forces to not
block the crossing points
because there are people that they
travel they're travelers they're
migrants
they need to travel
but
there was a location in kabul a few days
ago
they mentioned a few points
that because the prisons have been
really prisoners have been lose from
prisons
and
for that reason they have closed the
borders to stop criminals going out of
afghanistan to those countries
this was one point
the second
point is that there should be a check
and a system
in place
to be able to check people's documents
and passports
whether they are legitimately traveling
to
neighboring countries or not
criminals should not take advantage of
this situation
and cross the border into other
countries or come into the country
because these rules are used by normal
people but other people and business
people
and for this reason
there has been problems
for the people
not being able to cross the crossing
points
foreign
with china
[Music]
first of all
hopefully our relationship with
all our neighbors will be a very good
and sound and strong relationship
we want afghanistan to take advantage of
their
economic and financial growth as well
their cooperation is vital for survival
of afghanistan
and for this reason
china
should
cooperate
with afghans
with our government and we want to
establish a good relationship with them
that project which belongs to
afghanistan between afghanistan and
china we will do our best to fulfill it
in the best way
and we're just waiting for uh security
there are so many projects they're all
waiting for they're all waiting for uh
peace and security
to be
the electricity line the pipeline the
gas pipeline
project the circular
road
they're all waiting for security and
that will be implemented
reporter from singapore
um
yes
know
foreign
what's happening right
to your mind do they have the right to
speak their mind
and be on the same level on every level
in the society today
and will you stop further demonstrations
from happening
uh
[Music]
first of all the country is just out of
a very
crisis situation
at the moment
there's there can be some protestant
demonstrations by women or any other
group
the situation was disrupted and also it
was bad for the security and safety of
the
capital
because all parts of the government is
not
functional at the moment
once the government is announced
if there are any protests or any demands
that would be addressed
in due time
if you're just joining us we're just
watching a media briefing by the taliban
who have announced that they are in
complete control of the afghan province
of panshir
that's the uh
the valley north of the capital kabul uh
where there's been a lot of fighting
going on final pocket of territory which
had remained outside taliban rule the
spokesman
went on to say
that the taliban had tried to
negotiate
but the resistance
gave negative answers
referring there to the national
resistance front of afghanistan the nrf
who had been fighting with the taliban
in that valley
he also said
they would treat the people off that
valley no differently and would appoint
residents in various positions
in the
in that valley and no civilian
casualties were taken in the fighting
a couple of questions asked by members
of the media there about
when we're expected to hear about
a government being announced
and he said
they wanted to do the job properly and
that they wouldn't announce the
government until friday but it would be
an all-inclusive government
he also talked about kabul airport
and the fact that
it's been badly damaged
and but they did expect international
flights to resume soon
let's go to our correspondent charles
stratford who is in kabul who is also
listening in
to that press conference by zabihullah
mujahid the taliban spokesman
so what stood out for you
in that press conference because
up till now the nrf have been denying
these claims that they have lost the
valley what is your understanding now of
the situation
well certainly about two two two and a
half hours ago there was a tweet put out
by the nrf saying that there were small
pockets of resistance ongoing but
i think by and large um it's widely
understood now certainly according to
that very comprehensive
um and wide-ranging press conference by
zabihullah mojad
giving a lot of details there about
what's happened in the last 24 hours
um
you know we've got to take the taliban's
at face value here and he went into some
some detail saying that uh
according to him no civilians have been
hurt he said that the leadership of a
lot of the leadership of the panshiris
the nrf were out of the country
specifically he mentioned the former
vice president um who we knew or we we
believe was in the valley until recently
saying that he had escaped to tajikistan
and the taliban spokesperson there
saying that these these
this leadership panchiris in general are
welcome to return back to the country
and participate in
forming a unified country it was very
much a call for unity
um
as the taliban grapples with with trying
to bring political stability as it
grapples we're trying to get not only
national legitimacy but obviously
legitimacy on the international stage as
well we have heard so far other than
that simple statement put out as i say
which was a tweet from the nrf we've had
very little information coming out of
out of the panshir valley because of
course communication was cut off
electricity was cut off
the taliban spokesperson majahid saying
that there had been food shortages in
the valley as well he said that the
taliban were going to
provide food he said that the
electricity was going to be put back on
um and he said that uh panchiris should
be treated with just as much respect as
anybody else in this country so
uh very much the taliban reaching out
and trying to put their fears at rest
but as yet as i say we've had no
formal statement that we can confirm as
being made by the leadership or any
remnants of the leadership that may or
may not exist in this country of the nrf
we've had no response to that
but a telling press conference with so
many different topics
covered um
he mentioned the airport as you say and
he thanked the countries and and and the
turks for being very instrumental and on
the ground seemingly trying to get the
airport up and running as quickly as
possible he
he reached out to the international
community saying please
let in such the vital amount of
humanitarian aid that the country needs
to recover when we understand that
around half the population according to
the un needs that aid
um he spoke about the economy he spoke
about the neighbors and the importance
of borders being opened but the fact
that the taliban are very wary so they
say of allowing criminals what he
described as criminals in and out of the
country so many topics covered there but
yes much of today's emphasis certainly
on this what would be historical news
if indeed the taliban have taken full
control of the panchayat valley
many thanks for that our correspondent
charles stratford there for us in kabul
no doubt we will speak again